so look my biggest challenge with you is
I think you go a little overboard when
it comes on to supporting Trump and I
think it's inappropriate I know yeah
honestly like it's a little too much I
know people who are Mega people who love
him but you like not like dude yeah I
don't know how did your infatuation with
Trump I just think his hair and his
physical uh prowess and strength is so
incredible his golf game is unbelievable
and I consider golf a proxy towards
basically everything in life if you're a
good golfer the way Trump is yeah then
you're good at everything really I mean
that's that's the best that's am I say
but by the way do you miss them be
honest do I miss them so that there's
and a crazy question for you just a
crazy question for you like for me you
know how uh CNN ratings just came out
and ratings you know I don't know what
the numbers was we'll get into it here
in a minute uh worse in nine years I
don't know what the numbers were but if
you can pull up the article worse than
nine years right so do you think like
you sit there and you say like for
comedy yeah like comedians
you know a great comedian maybe can do
make fun of everybody yeah okay Schultz
he can do anybody Chappelle can do
anybody Rogan these guys can't do
anybody right you know but sometimes
like the market needs a good president
to make fun of yeah right so you know
there's a lot you can do with Biden but
there's a lot more you can do with oh
absolutely and he's he's so funny in
spite of himself yeah and sometimes it's
he'll say one thing like he'll call you
know the the CEO of Lockheed Marilyn
Lockheed but that's not her name her
name's her last name is not the name of
the company that's funny in the moment
Tim Apple Tim apple right there's these
art I said Tim Cook you pretty much said
Tim Apple there's this Arc like for
example where Trump weirdly gets
obsessed with toilets during his during
his 2020 campaign I don't know if you
guys remember this but he would go to
rallies and he would go and they're
they're turning down the flow on my
toilets you're gonna have to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times and I'm thinking
what is Trump doing with a toilet where
you need 10 flushes right it's weird but
that's just the first piece so then on
Election night when he talks about how
he really won you know which he lost
um he he says what they were massive
dumps in the middle of the night and
you're like 15 flushes massive dumps and
then later for you later that was good
later you find out he was flushing
documents down the toilet so you're like
going back a year that's the reason the
toilet he was so concerned about toilets
he's flushing documents himself so how
do you handle the whole uh uh you know
but even for yourself as a content
creator do you miss him as a con like
would you selfishly forget about
political of course you don't want him
you would have probably had Bernie over
Biden I would assume maybe somebody else
who would have been your guy if you had
your choice yeah I mean I I think Bernie
is the closest when you look at policy
to me but I've been very critical of the
way Bernie runs his campaign I Bernie
talks about he's a socialist I don't
know I'm not a socialist and I don't
actually think Bernie ran on a socialist
platform but we can get to that but I
I've said to my audience Trump was great
for shows like mine there's no question
about it right like speaking if I was if
I was Voting not for what I think is
best for the country but what's best for
me financially of course Trump was a
gold mine there's no question about it
so who who did you want like if you were
to say like today you have your choice
on who can be the president who would
you like
it's the the reason I'm going to answer
the question but the reason that it's a
hard question to answer in that way is
there's policy and there's who could win
who would be good at governing who can
who understands how to make compromise
and sort of how politics is done so I
think there's a ton of really
interesting people that do well in all
of these areas and and I'll give you a
few names and I from this is now for my
audience because if what I'm about to
say they'll say you you're just the
insult in my space is you're a lib
meaning I'm not aggressive I'm not left
enough right okay I think folks like
it's it's crazy yeah I think the people
that are striking the right balance
right now between policy and rhetoric
and ability to actually be good
politicians are people like and this is
gonna be crazy okay Gavin Newsom Pete
bootage Stacy Abrams Katie Porter in
California I think these are really
interesting folks who I don't
necessarily agree with them on all
policy but I think they bring a few
things that are important they're
younger right now I think there's a
problem where it's it's sort of like old
guy after old guy after old guy on both
sides we're seeing this to a degree so I
like that I think they bring some
Progressive policies that are
interesting without really being
brandable as being socialists and I
think that that's all really important
right now for the for the left so what
do you like about so okay so let's let's
stay with who we currently have right
now so today Biden yeah what's he doing
good what do you think he's not doing
good okay so if I were to say here are
the things that Biden got done that are
accomplishments that are important and
you know think things that that are
worth doing at a time where I think it
was necessary he did that third coveted
stimulus remember Trump did two of them
and Biden Biden did a third one I think
at the time it made sense and he didn't
include as much of this or really any if
I recall the PPP slush fund which was so
fraudulently used and now you know the
IRS is backed up on audits in part
because they're doing PPP fraud
investigation so I like that he didn't
include that I didn't think that that
was necessary inflation reduction act
does a lot of interesting things and
whether or not it quote reduces is
inflation inflation is coming down now
several months in a row I love the
renewable energy stuff that's in there I
drive an electric car I've got the solar
panels I've got you know my gas stove
I'm even going to get rid of I'm ready
I'm ready to get rid of them I'm being
dead serious no yeah you're fully
committed it's not a commitment it's the
induction is unbelievable once you
actually learn to use it it's fantastic
I was repeating oh you get the gas stove
you can modulate down to the it's
beautiful I've now cooked with induction
it's fantastic so I'm I'm fully I think
it's fantastic I think encouraging that
we're not Banning gas stoves of course
I'm exaggerating I think that that's
really great
um I think getting getting out of
Afghanistan I think was the absolute
right decision many criticisms of the
chaos that unfolded when Trump was asked
how would you have done it differently
he didn't actually have any answer it
was Trump's plan to get out that Biden
did a few months later because Trump
never got to it for whatever reason I
think that was the right decision it was
going nowhere 20 years there Etc
um on student loan forgiveness I don't
know what's going to happen eventually
I'm not a forgive all student loans guy
some in my audience are like David all
loans should be forgiven it's like no I
don't think so I don't think that makes
sense but we've had programs like if
you're a doctor and you work in an
underserved Community long enough you
qualify to get those loans forgiven I
think certain programs like that make a
lot of sense so I think that that's a
good thing okay so if you enjoyed this
clip you want to see another one click
here to watch another clip and if you
want to take advantage the latest gold
Signature Series products that just came
out we have a bunch of new merch that's
out this is a color changing mug when
you drink coffee that lion turns into a
real lion and then we have hoodies wood
value team and gold on it the gold
Signature Series hat shirts I'm an
entrepreneur anyways we have a lot of
items they're selling out if you want to
take advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valuetainment
foreign
[Music]